e
ask your
name name
is Monday and
Wednesday e
does no next to
you Peter
right yeah
let's talk after okay
folks so I'm going to ask at the start
of every
class by the by the time I get to the
end of Monday and Wednesday my voice is
getting a little Fray so I don't want to
lose my voice entirely if you guys could
Qui down a little bit you can hear
me at the start of every class for the
next four
sessions I'm going to ask two
questions okay and then I'm going to
stop here's the first question how many
of you have picked a
company to value for your project how
many of you picked I would look around
right most of you haven't this question
is is going to get reframed next week
next week when I ask this question I'm
going to ask you how many of you have
not picked your company because by then
hopefully most of you have transitioned
second question if you picked your
company did you remember you don't have
to answer this did you remember to go
put your company name down on the master
list somebody had actually tried to fill
out the rest of the master list for the
moment all I need is your company you
don't put a DCF valuation if you've done
that you don't need the rest of the
class obviously you got it all nailed
down so all I need for the moment is the
name of your company with the right to
change it right so I'm not going to hold
you to it I just want you to pick a damn
company and start moving on this because
otherwise you're going to go back and
forth until week eight before you pick a
company so today we're going to start on
the meat and potatoes part of valuation
we're going to start talking about the
inputs come up with discount rates
especially risk free
rates so I'm going to start with the
start of the class test like I always do
and this is going to revolve around risk
free rates I want to pick somebody from
Brazil to be my guinea pick there must
be somebody in this class from Brazil
right oh there you go
yeah so the rest of you can go along
there's no Brazil specific experience
you need to answer this question I just
want to pick on a Brazilian for the
moment so let's say you're valuing a
Brazilian company
right and you're trying to pick a
currency to do the valuation you can
value it in re or you can value it in US
Dollars and I give you the risk free
rate today we'll talk about how to get
risk free rates in R and US Dollars you
might say it's obvious but let's see
let's say the risk- free rate in R is 7
and a half% and the risk- free rate in
US dollars is two and a half% you ready
you're on the you're on the stage now I
can value this company in r with the
seven half% risk free rate or I can
value the same company in dollars with a
2 and a half% risk free rate which one
which currency choice is going to give
you the higher
value doesn't matter that's actually the
right answer tell me why it doesn't
matter because I mean let's let me give
you play Devil's Advocate which one's
going to give you a higher discount rate
you start with the risk free rate of 7
and a half or two and a half which one's
going to give you a higher discount
rate come on don't think too long you
start with a higher number you're going
to end up with a higher discount rate
right so the discount rate in R is going
to be higher than the discount and I
thought in discounted cash flow
valuation the discount rate goes up the
value should go down so tell me what's
happening where that's off something has
to be happening to offset it so what do
you think is happening that's allowing
this higher discount rate to get Offset
you can stay you can
try let's isolate that right the
business is the business so where does
currency actually show up in the cash
flows what dimension does it affect
you're selling the same number of
products the same number of customers
the same business model all I'm doing is
switching currencies right basically
question I'm asking is why do risk free
rates vary across currencies one of the
things we're going to examine
today and whatever makes the discount
rate I'm going to leave it mysterious at
this moment whatever makes your risk
free rate higher in a
currency will also show up in your cash
flows in the exactly proportionate
manner I'm going to leave whatever that
is
mysterious and if you do this right you
will get the same value for your company
whether you're valuing US Dollars
Brazilian RS British pounds euros and
this is incredibly good news you know
why when you pick a company pick a
currency and just stay true to it what
gets people into trouble is going back
and forth you want to Value Russian
company so fear is you can value in
Rubles God help you if you do go down
that path or you can value it in Euros
or
dollars God help you that way too right
so either way so but if you do it right
you get the same
value and I'll give you the analogy I
want you to think about to understand
why currency doesn't
matter what's the temperature today in
new
york0 are you European oh you're okay
what's your temperature you think it's
Fahrenheit right
32 is so much higher than six he must
live in a hotter part of New York than
he does right the only difference is the
talk Celsius and Fahrenheit it's really
like 40 degrees Fahrenheit or
42 can you make a hot place colder by
just stating the temperature in
celsius i l up in Delhi in July of any
year it's going to be hot whether I
State the temperature in Fahrenheit or
Celsius because it's a measurement
device currency is a measurement device
I can't make a great company into an
awful Company by switching currencies
and conversely I can't take an awful
currency and make it into a great
currency it requires a lot of gymnastics
along the way we'll talk about what you
have to do to be careful that this hopes
let me follow up on the currency doesn't
matter can I do evaluation with currency
entirely out of the
process it's called real valuation real
cash flows not REI but real real cash
flows and real discount rates what's a
real discount rate real cash flows just
reflect what you would make as a company
if you could never raise prices you have
constant prices and you just have to to
grow you to sell more units so cash
flows are real cash flows there's no
inflation
embedded your discount rate then has to
also be a real discount
rate which will also have no inflation
embedded you're saying where's inflation
showing up in your risk rate that again
we will try to make explicit today there
is a linkage there again if you do this
right and I'm going to answer the
question for you because it follows from
the first one doing everything in real
terms which is a 0% inflation your cash
flows and a 0% inflation in your
discount rate will give you the same
value you know what parts of the world
people used to do things in real terms
in the near inflation rate is 5,000% do
you ever want to do things in nominal
terms venezuel I'm going to use a 5,000%
God help you you start with 5,000% and
build up the zeros on your Excel
spreadsheet are going to start building
up over time as well so you say look I'm
going to take inflation entirely out of
the picture inflation doesn't go away as
a problem you're just removing it from
the exercise to make your exercise more
management so we'll talk more about how
inflation plays our risk free rates but
that's going to be the starting
point let's keep
going the US bond rate is often used as
risk free in US dollars we'll talk about
whether that's okay
right we spent a decade with abnormally
low t- Bond rates during the last decade
the average t- bond rate was about two
and a half per. just to give you
perspective it was 6 and a half% in the
80s 5% in the 90s 4 and a half% the in
the first decade but last decade it was
down to about 2 and a half per. if you
listen to a lot of CNBC which is a bad
mistake I would break that habit quickly
and asked you why were risk-free rates
low in the last decade the answer you
usually get is the Fed kept it La doing
what Q qe1 QE2 Titanic quantitative
easing all kinds of Buzzy words come out
but the FED keeps rates low and this is
a
fixation every time the FED Open Market
Committee meets all of CNBC comes and
stand still it's like a pope being
elected what's a small going to say gray
smoke the rates are going up it's
amazing how the whole world has become
this waiting place for what will the FED
do so we're going to start to break some
of these bad practices right now do you
think the FED has been what's kept
keeping rates low for the last decade
you're you're saying no but no why not
no because I hear from CNBC all the time
about fed keeping rates low it's going
to raise rates what's the only rate that
fed sets you
know it's an overnight interbank
borrowing rate called the FED funds rate
when was the last time you borrowed at
the FED funds rate I tried actually the
Federal Reserve you can have this little
um tour it's actually a neat tour they
take you around the the best part is
they take you down to the basement to
the mint and you can see the currency
don't try anything rash it's well
protected that right said can you show
me the FED funds window I'd like to
borrow money and the lady I lady was
taking on the tour said no you can't
borrow at that rate it's the only rate
they
said can they influence interest rates
yes but they don't set rates the rates
we're talking about are either Market
set like the t- bond rate or driven by
market rates like your mortgage
rate in fact what did the FED do last
September cut rates I read the headline
fed Cuts rates you know what happened to
interest rates for the rest of the year
they all went up
so we're going to get to the heart of
the FED delusion and how I think it's
getting in the way of us thinking
sensibly about interest rates this
fixation with the Federal Open Market
Committee meeting and deciding has to go
it's actually getting in the way of
sensible thinking about what is it that
drives interest
rates which leaves you with a final
issue with risk free rates that's been
driving people a little crazy for the
last decade the last few years there
have been at least a couple of
currencies where the risk-free rate has
turned negative and this freaks people
out why because in econ classes you
never saw this coming right it's
supposed to be a in know rate to to for
current consumption versus future and
it's always a positive number in class
and here it is negative Wass Frank
Japanese
Yen when risk-free rates turn negative
I've heard people say you cannot do
valuation anymore you can see how the
logic works right the risk fre rate
turns negative discount rate is going to
become really low when your discount
rate becomes really low your valuations
are going to
explode I think the reason they w't is
the answer given to the Brazilian R
question we'll talk about where in the
process or what the messages you're
getting from negative risk free rates
and trust me it's not an uplifting
message about the future you don't want
to live in a world with negative risk
free rates because the signals you're
getting about what the future will
deliver and I've seen people in this
case actually place the rate today with
a normalized rate you're saying what's a
normalized rate the heck NOS so what do
you do you take the last 40 years your
average rate over the last 4 said that I
I tell people you tell me how old you
are I'll tell you what your normal is
going to look like cuz you're really old
you going back to the 1980s right you
not that old you might go back 20 years
you're really young might go back 5
years and guess what your normal rates
are all over the place terrible practice
but we'll talk about what drove people
to that practice and why it's a
dangerous practice
a lot on our plate we have to talk about
why risk free rates vary across
currencies we have to talk about how to
get real risk free rates and also talk
about what central banks do in this
process that might or might not affect
rates so let's go back to where I left
you on Wednesday we're talking about you
don't even remember right there was a
last week we had class last week we did
a lot of stuff in the class it's kind of
gone by
but we talked about cash flows to
equity and cash flows The Firm we talked
about consistency cash flows to equity
you discounted the cost of equity cash
flow The Firm you discount the cost of
capital if you discount cash flows The
Firm at the cost of capital you get the
value of the entire business but let's
say you're interested in just the equity
because that's what you're going to buy
shares in so my first question and this
is directed at those of you worked in
banking last summer and did this you
know mechanically is what do you
subtract ra out from the value of the
firm to get the value equ and I'll give
you the choices you can subtract out the
value of just long-term debt you can
subtract the value of all debt which
includes shortterm debt as well you can
subtract the value of any debt that you
call debt in your cost of capital
calculation or you can just go crazy and
subtract out all liabilities current
liabilities all the rest of sub they're
all liabilities on my balance which of
these choices should be off the table
right
off D take that out right that's that's
a bludgeon it's not going to work the
question is which of the first three you
want to try what do you think I should
subtract
down okay that's good did you use that
in your cost of capital as
well if you're going to why would use
two sets of rules and why you
subtracting all debt when you do this
and not do all debt when you do cost of
capital fine you can have it in both
places right so I can understand the
logic for all Deb but why just stop
there my question is why isn't C doing
what B would have done anyway right
because if you do this right shouldn't
debt be debt in both
places which should be and not
necessarily right let's take an example
before
2019 accountants didn't treat leases as
debt right so now they do but let's
suppose 3E 2019 so when I did cost to
Capital pre 2019 I I did this it treated
Lee as dead brought it in as dead my
cost cap we talk about the mechanics of
doing it but then when I got to the end
I had to subtract out my debt number not
the debt number you see in a balance
sheet you see the reason you have to
match up the two is if you don't you
have two stories in your valuation that
are not quite
set the reason I threw the long-term
debt and therefore some reason there are
Bankers who seem to think only long-term
debt is debt I don't think they've ever
borrowed money I think they need to
borrow money from a money lender
preferably because the lessons will I
think get reinforced more you borrow
money for two weeks from a money lender
you don't pay your debt you say just
short-term debt you know what's going to
happen you're going to have two broken
knees and then you will remember that
all debt is debt shortterm as well as
longterm so this is a stupid dance
shortterm or longterm we'll talk about
why we don't bring current liabilities
into debt and it's a very mechanical
reason but ultimately you tell me what
debt you have in your cost of capital
that's going to be the Deb you subtract
and if you do that should you get the
same value for Equity that you got by
taking cash flows equity and discounting
at the cost of equ let me reframe the
question would you like to get the same
value I would because and you imagine
being a equity research analyst they buy
using Equity valuation model sell using
a firm valuation you won't be an equity
research analyst for very
long so let's try whe to see if they get
and this is a madeup exam example and
it's a madeup example where I made
implicit assumptions that going to lead
me to my finding so here I have a
business I've cash flows Equity those
are pre cash flows after debt payments
I've added the only debt payment here
let's assume it's only interest expenses
and I've got a cash flow to the
firm I've got a cost of equity of
13.625 and I can borrow longterm at 10%
as a pre-tax cost to
borrow the company has a market value of
equity of 1,73 million it and you should
already be a little suspicious because
the numbers look a little two third
decimal four decimal is and there's a
reason for that in a moment you're going
to see but I've given you all the
information to both value the company
based on Equity as well as fir let's
first try discounting cash flows Equity
the cost of equity so I take each cash
flow these should be raised to the power
I'm sorry for some reason that the two
should be raised the power so I take the
first Year's cash flow discount back one
year second Year's cash flow
discount back two years and you add up
the present
values the value that you get for the
equity discounted cash flow Equity at
the cost of equities 1,73 million the
company is fairly value but if I take
the cash flow to the firm and discounted
back at the cost of capital which is a
weighted average of my cost of equity in
my cost of debt and remember debt brings
a tax advantage so 10% rate becomes a 5%
rate what I get as a present value is
1,873 million
then what do I do I subtract out the
debt 800 million and boil up got magic I
get exactly I've cheated along the way
you didn't see where I cheated but I
ended up with the same answer for My
Equity either way there was a weekly
challenge I gave you last week which I
don't think any of you would have tried
I wouldn't want you to try that weekly
challenge today when you get a chance
because it's an exercise and what
happens when you do this in a real form
because you actually will get different
PR aners for the equity and I'm going to
ask you what is it that we're doing
that's causing the values of equity it's
one of the most difficult exercise
valuation it's unfair to throw it at you
right at the start of the class but it's
good to start wrestling with the
implicit assumptions we make when you do
valuation so the bottom line when you
value companies is make a choice first
this same thing with currency and stick
with that if you want to Value Equity
make everything about Equity un value
The Firm make it every make everything
about the firm
there are so many different ways you
could screw up so let me establish the
first consistency principle and there
going to be other consistency principles
that come in when you discount cash
flows you tell me how you estimate the
cash flows I'll tell you the discount
rate that goes with if your cash flows
are after debt payments I use cost of
equity cash flows to the firm I use cost
to Capital mixing and matching cash
flows is an absolute
disaster remember the
kot you can get every cash flow right
but if you use the wrong discount rate
all that work is down the
train put a big X on this page because
when you're doing your quiz you might
get a little flustered and start reading
off the wrong
page these are things you shouldn't do
so if you take cash flows to equity and
discounted the cost of capital you will
overstate the value of
equity which is
what first Boston did with carb random
because they discounted cash flow if you
take cash flows of firm and discounted
the cost of equity it will go the other
direction you will undervalue the
equity and if you discount cash flows
firm at the cost of equity and forget to
subtract our debt God help you I don't
even know what you ended up with just
because you have a DN CF doesn't mean
you have a discounted cash flow
valuation so the next time you see a d
you have the tools now at least to take
it apart what's a cash flow what's a
discount rate do they match up if they
don't the rest of the valuation is moved
it doesn't really matter
so what I'd like to do actually is set
up intrinsic valuation the pieces that
go in I'm going to show you a big
picture page of what the different
pieces are and then I'm going to talk
about three different ways that DCF can
be structured two are Equity ways and
the third is
airm so you look at discount cash flow
valuation here are the
ingredients you have cash flows those
cash flows can be either before debt or
after debt if they're before debt they
cash flows airm if they're after debt
the cash flows de
your discount rate can either be to the
entire firm cost of capital or it can be
just to equity which is the cost of
equity and even your growth rate can be
different because when I ask about
growth in equity cash flows you're
focused on Equity investors you care
about Equity income net income earnings
per share but you're looking at the
entire firm the growth rate you have to
be talking about is growth and operating
income which is before interest expenses
already you can see every question you
ask is framed by the choice you made up
front it's equity everything stays in
equity terms it's a firm everything get
stated in firm
terms so I'm going to start with the
simplest discounted cash flow model
around this is the model it's been
around almost a 100 years it's called
the dividend discount model it comes
with consequences because you're
assuming companies going pay out what
they can afford to and I'm going to
value a company based on
dividends and when you do that you can
basically see that I'm focused on what
companies pay which in the case of
Google is what just started paying
dividends if it's Invidia how much is
Invidia paying
dividends make a guess nothing they pay
zero dividends wish are 100% so if I did
a dividend disc kind model value of
Nidia what might I get that it's worth
nothing now we can debate how much
Invidia is worth but it's definitely
worth more than nothing right but in the
dividend discount model you keep your
eyes on dividends your growth rate is
growth in equity income and dividend
your discount rate is a cost of equity
because dividend is an equity cash flow
and what you get as a present value will
be the value of equity in the company so
that's a dividend
discount if I'm
doing dividend so I'm assuming companies
are paying out what they can afford to
inage do companies pay out what they can
afford to IND divage how do we know that
they don't there is conclusive proof on
the balance sheet that Apple doesn't pay
out what it can afford to divid what
wrong side of the balance sheet though
because you might be paying exactly what
you should you retain earnings too big
great now Coca-Cola pays roughly what it
can afford to retain earnings a huge go
the other side of the B there's an
item look at the cash balance how much
cash does Apple
have almost 200 billion how did it get
there not Mana from
Heaven it's a direct consequence of the
company not paying out what it can
afford to so if I do it dividend
discount model valuation of Apple I am
going to undervalue the company why
because I'm not counting out the cash
flows they could have paid out so how
the heck do I know that can I estimate
how much could have paid out we're going
to talk about a process as I said this
is a big picture we're not there yet of
estimating these potential divid I'm
going to call it free cash Ro Equity
it's a fancy word for potential dividend
it's what's left over after every other
need has been met if I don't like
dividends if I look at a come like apple
and say hey Dividends are not a
realistic measure of what Equity
investors get I can focus on free cash
flow equ the growth rate then will be in
equity income and free cash FL Equity
your discount rate is still a cost of
equity free cash FL equity and what you
get as a present value will be the value
of equity the companies when you close
the
process and let's do the final leg I
could look at cash flows before debt
payments to get to cash flows before
debt payments I have to start with
operating income net income is already
you know after interest expense so I've
got to climb the income
statement but this cash flow will be
before debt payment before interest in
principal payment again we'll come back
and talk about the specific of capex and
depreciation working capital all that
neat stuff but we're estimating cash
flows before de payments if that's a
cash flow of discounting the growth I
should be talking about is growth in
operating income and free cash flow to
the
firm the discount
rate has to be a cost of
capital and I can can shut this Pro and
I'll talk about the significance of
shutting the process down when your free
cash flows start to grow at a Conant you
see what they are I mean you could put
them next to each other you can see
already they're trying to do the same
thing the only difference is how you
define cash flows and the discount rate
that
goes so if you ever get confused FCF FCF
dividend look at this table because it
kind of shows what they have in common
and what makes them different so if
you're doing a dividend discount model
here's how it'll look like once you're
done you're going to project out
expected dividends next year to years
know to do that you'll have to first
project out earnings growth and what
they will pay out as a percentage of
earnings two inputs growth and payout
ratio you get expected dividends and
you'll discount those dividends back at
a cost of equity reflecting the risk of
the equity for the moment again all
these things you say I don't know what a
payout ratio what a bet is will come
back and nail them down but everything
is focused on
dividence one of the the reasons I
talked about cash flows growing at a
constant rate forever is you can't keep
doing this
forever to stop at some point in time
right you run out of columns in Excel
what
16,48 you run out of patience about 16,4
74 columns earlier so in all of
discounted cash flow valuation there's a
closure point where you stop and you
estimate what's called a terminal value
what is the terminal value do it
captures the present value of all cash
flows beyond that point in time it's the
most dangerous number number in
valuation because this is where you get
yourself into trouble we're going to
spend a lot of time on that but
everything in a dividend discount model
is built around expected dividends if
you look at a free cash flow to equity
model it looks exactly the same the only
difference is you're replacing dividends
with this potential dividend you're
still going through the process of what
will it grow at when will it become
stable and then you discount back at the
cost of equity what you get as a present
value will be the value equi in a
company I know I'm belabor these big
pictures but I want you to compare them
to each other because I want you to see
what they have in common as much as what
they have in differences you're doing
the same thing they're all discounted
cash flow models it's only how you
estimate cash flows and what discount
rate you p and finally if you look at
free cash FL The Firm models you replace
free cash or Equity the pre-ad cash
flows the cost of capital your growth
rate becomes a growth in operating
income so you look at what drives that
your discount rate becomes a cost of
capital and what you get as a present
value is the value of the operating
assets the company why operating assets
because you valued only those assets
whose income is part of operating I
don't want to be
mysterious in the case of Apple what
have I not valued yet when I discount
free cash to the firm at the cost of
capital it's a big a I just mentioned it
what's a big asset they have that whose
income is not part of operating
income cash income from cash is not part
of operating this is where if you're
accounting is a little soft I'll leave
it at that word you will have trouble we
said really interest interest income is
not part of operating income it shows up
below the operating income line it shows
up as part part of net income so you
know what that means right if I discount
free cash with the firm at the cost of
capital for Apple I haven't valued $200
billion this is in Penny change you
can't just leave it away you got to add
it in we'll talk about the Dark Side of
cross Holdings and what they do for
companies and I let leave that at that
but there's a lot of mopping up to do
I'm going to call these Loose Ends to
get from the value The Firm to Value
backward and we'll spend two sessions on
just these loose
sets dividend discount model free cash
or Equity free cash with the firm they
all try to do the same thing which is
discounted cash flow valuation and this
is why I'm always wary when somebody
says I do DCF I've done a DCF for a
company told me anything what cash flows
do you use what discount rate do you use
because until you give me those
specifics I'm not even sure what a DCF
even
means so now let's talk about process
how many know only a few of you picked a
company you can start this process this
evening so what's your what's your
mission you said you pick a company
right what's your
mission to Value this company right so
what do you have to do you have to
forecast the future where you going to
start this
process
start common sense you start with the
past you're saying what if I don't have
much of a pass well that's all you can
take take what you can get if you have a
young company it might be two years you
have an old company it could be 15 years
you start with the past so the game
always starts by looking at the past I'm
going to try to see if I
can so starts the past so when you're
looking at the past and and this is a
general question you take your company
let's say you picked a company you
looked at the Last 5 Years last 10 years
what are you looking for what what are
some of the things you're trying to get
rid of
there here's the first thing don't get
caught in the details because you're
going to get so lost in the details that
you will not be able to get your head
above water you know what I mean by that
accounting classes they ask you to
compute all these ratios and before you
know you got 200 different ratios
computed for your company amazing job
but you have no idea why you even
computed them there are three core
questions you're trying to get a sense
of by looking at the past first is how
quickly is my company
growing see why this matters right if
you're going to tell a story about your
company and your company's been growing
at 2% a year for the last 10 years you
have to be a little skeptical about
saying I'll grow 20% a year for the next
de so you're going to look at past
growth and the metric which you should
focus on to measure look at growth is
revenues because revenues don't lie
income does you can do accounting games
and increase your earnings so I'm going
look at Revenue Grow Again to get a
sense of how doesn't mean the past is
prolonged right so just because you have
a high Revenue Growth Company for the
last 10 years doesn't mean it's going to
be high in the future but at least you
have a
starting but growth alone doesn't make
you valuable right as you grow what do
you have to
do make money so the second stop you're
going to make is how profitable has my
company been in the past
anybody want willing to put up their
accounting Jennifer you want to be my
accounting guinea pig and you look at an
income
statement you can compute all kinds of
profit margins you know profit margin is
right you take a profit divide by
revenues there are three big margin
numbers you can get out of an income
statement there's gross margin there's
operating margin there's net margin so
Jennifer help me out what is gross
margin in
measure no take any year so when I look
at any year let's say because next year
I don't have the numbers let's say I
look at 2024 numbers so Tyler is going
to jump in and I'll come back to you so
Tyler what is gross margin
meas Revenue minus cogs and this is the
problem when we get into accounting
acronyms is we say what the heck is cogs
what what the heck is
cogs but know what what what does it
measure how
much that's not necessarily true gross
margin basically measures unit economics
it measures the cost of the stuff you
sold so if you are you know software
company it's a cost of making the you
know the cost of this making that extra
software unit which is close to zero
right so you get an Microsoft and you
order another cop copy of Office 36 65
there is a little you know whatever
person at Microsoft writing I've got to
make another copy so the cost of goods
sold is going to be tiny at Microsoft
because whereas if you're a
Manufacturing Company even the most
efficient one it's so it's unit
economics unit economics basically
measures how much money do you make on
the next unit you sell you saying I'd
like that number to be high we all do
but you pick a business it comes with
unity economics so gross margin measures
Unity economics
operating margin what do you do you take
the gross profits and then you subtract
out things like R&D and GNA which are
not directly related to the next unit
that you Ser but you have to do to
operate as a
company so when you look at operating
margins you're getting a sense of
economies of scale I want you to stop
thinking about these words as Buzz
wordss because every Company claims have
economies of scale every company says
they have great unit economics check the
numbers if they have great unit econom
eics their grow margins have to be high
if they big economies of scale here's
what's going to should happen as the
company grows it's operating margin
should increase right because it's cost
that's what economies of scale means
your costs are growing at a lower rate
than Revenue so you're looking at gross
margin as a measure of unity economics
operating we'll come back and kind of
nail this down more with actual
companies operating margin as what is
net margin what what causes the
operating margin to diverge from net
margin
primarily how much debt to use you know
what the gross margin for Nidia was in
the last 12
months close to
80% why why I mean it's a semiconductor
chip company doesn't it so what does it
tell you about the
company they design chips they don't
make the chips tsmc makes the chips for
them they mark them up immensely why
because everybody wants AI
chips the gross margins are or 80% those
are those are no sple
margins I mean that those might be
higher than those might be the highest
margins the S&P 500 you know the
operating margin
is it's close to
70% now do you see why the company's
worth three trillion it's not just that
they've grown but it's a money
machine will it stay money machine
that's what your valuation is going to
try to answer is so you're just looking
at the past you to get Clues you look at
Revenue growth you look at
margins and then you look to answer a
final question to grow what did they
have to do how much did they have to
invest so you're a Manufacturing Company
I'm looking to see how many factories
you had to build you saying why does
that matter because that growth now has
to be offset again what you reinvested
I'm measuring how efficiently you
deliver the growth and if you're company
that got a lot of growth with very
little reinvestment I'm going to reward
you more because that's a great business
model
but if you're a cruise line company and
you keep buying these cruise ships every
year you can show me a growing 30% but
I'm not going to be that
impressed growth profitability
efficiency of growth that's what you're
trying to get Clues to by looking at the
past so let's say you look at the last
five years you get some clues in your
company it's a moderate Growth Company
with decent margins it's reinvested not
incredibly but reasonably
well it's all coming from the past right
this is where you got to leave your
comfort zone because what's theob your
job in valuation is to look to see what
this will look like in the future and
your first reaction is going to be I
don't
know iight through that moment because
none of us does you have to make your
best Testament you could take the lazy
way out which is what a lot of bankers
and analysts do which is I don't know so
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
just extrapolate the
past you take the revenue growth from
the last 10 years you applied for the
next 10 years you take the Marg in the
last 10 years you applied for the next
10 years you're saying what can go wrong
what can go wrong you're a Canadian
Lumber Company and I do this your entire
business model changed today right what
can go wrong is the world keep shifting
around you deep seep comes around maybe
invidious margins are not going to be as
strong thank God those things happen see
saying that's weird why would you want
something like that because if all I had
to do was extrap at the past value a
company I don't need you right or a
person chpt could go do it for you some
AI engine can do that for you you can
automate the entire thank God things
happen that change that those historical
Pathways because that's where you will
come in with the
evaluation so what we're going to do
then is to forecast the future and here
I'm going to give you two
Pathways one is the most General pathway
and I'll Define how we're going to Value
companies you're going to project the
revenue growth in the future we look at
the factors that play into whether you
can continue the pass whether you got a
break from the P lower
higher then you're going to project
margins in the future right and they can
go up it's in the case of invarious
stuff because you're already at the top
but if you're valuing a company with
very low margin say they're going to cut
cost margins can change and finally I'm
going to ask you how much will you have
to reinvest to get that Revenue growth
Revenue growth margins reinvestment keep
it simple those are ultimately the three
drivers of your cash flows you can dance
around those break them down to 500 line
items but ultimately that's what's going
to give you cash so that's a general
approach to forecasting free cash flow
there's a special case and I'll talk
about the special case not because there
are that many of the special case but
it's going to help us in the closure
part if if you have a company with
stable margins and stable Returns on
Capital you know what kind of company it
be let's say conad what does conet do
supplies a parts utility it's regulated
U it's been around forever we assume
that that regulated monopo is going to
stay and you say the margins are pretty
much set their returns are pretty much
set I'm going to give you an easy way
out forecasting cash flows rather than
forecast the growth in revenues I'm
going to ask you to forecast two other
numbers one is a reinvestment rate the
percentage of your after tax oper income
that you put back into the business so
if you have know revenues of you know
after tax oper income of 100 million you
put back 40 million into you know plant
and equipment and machinary and whatever
else that's a 40% reinvestment rate and
a return on Capital which is what you
can make on your projects again you say
I have no idea you can look at the past
but you have to make that judgment in
the future your reinvestment rate times
your return on Capital will give you the
growth rate you don't have to estimate
growth rate but that's only if margins
are
stable so the reason I'm laying that out
is later on we're going to talk about
when you can take that path in your
company but until you get there you got
to do revenues margins reinvestment and
in discounting all of this what do you
need a Coster cap I'm afraid we've
already ruined you in finance classes
because we ask you to talk about risk
and cost of capital we've already R in
beta standard deviate I want to step
back and give you the intuitive feel for
what you're trying to
estimate to get a cost of capital I need
a cost of equity and I need a cost of
debt everybody agree two numbers let's
start with the easier number first what
goes into a cost of debt you're a you're
a banker you're lending money to me in
US Dollars let's keep the currency
you're going to see why currency matters
how you going to decide what interest
rate charge what are you going to start
with as your base
yes which in the U because I'm doing it
in us and this is why currency matter is
is going to be let's say the T Bond R
right now it's about 4. 55%
4.6% will you lend money to me at the
risk free rate if you did how long would
you last as a banker not very long why
because I could
default so what do you do you add a
spread on top of the risk R right again
don't let the the buzzword get in you're
going to add a spread and the rot chars
and the 1500s probably had to do do it
as well which reflects the risk you see
in my company credit risk default risk
risk free rate plus a default spread is
going to give me my cost today and then
the government steps in and says you
borrowed money that's amazing we'll help
you out by doing what you borrow money
what is the advantage you get which you
don't get when you have Equity you get a
tax reduction how many of you do your
own
taxes you don't have income you don't
have taxes so but soon you'll be doing
your own taxes somebody will be doing
your
taxes if you you're doing your taxes you
have interest expenses no okay so you're
not there yet but you at some point in
time you'll be wealthy enough for
interest expenses you know what you're
allowed to claim your interest expenses
as a tax reduction which effectively
makes the cost of debt lower because
when you borrow money at 8% and I give
you a 30% tax rate benefit you're
effectively borrowing money at 5.6% you
see how I got from the 8 to the 5.6 8%
times one mon is a tax rate that's a
cost of Deb that's the easy part what's
the cost of equity it's a number you had
in your heads when you bought my shares
this is going to be a nightmare to
estimate why because I want to be able
to read your minds assume I can don't
worry I can also if you're thinking
about something else you say let's say I
went around reading each of your
minds what's the next problem I'm going
to face did you all have the same number
in your minds
each of you might have a different
number and I have to come up with one
cost of equity for 50 years probably 70
years in finance we've wrestled with how
do you come up with one cost of equity
or Invidia when you have all these
thousands of people own
shares and you know how we got through
and solved that does anybody else own
shares in Nidia besides
me okay
good what's in our minds doesn't really
matter what why we don't own enough
shares I took a look at the top 10
shareholders in inedia you know the
largest
shareholders vard owns 8.5% of the
shares in Nvidia 8.5% of the
shares big institutional investors and
that gives me an escape hatch because
now I'm going to say look it's not all
shareholders I care about it's the
marginal shareholders who are the
marginal shareholders they're the
shareholders who own a lot of shares and
trade those
shares Vanguard Black Rock I look down
the list State
Street now what's in vanguard's Port
for
everything everything is in there right
they they Ser as Pension funds but you
think of what they hold they hold every
single stock in the market so when they
think about the risk in Invidia it's a
risk that they add on to their portfolio
this is the Breakthrough that gave gave
rise to finances a discipline Harry
Marco it's walking in to that library in
Princeton saying the risk of a stock is
not based on how much it moves but how
much risk it adds to a portfolio the
rest is pure
mechanics so when you talk about betas
it builds on the presumption that the
risk in a stock is a risk added to a
portfolio right we'll talk about what if
that assumption is wrong because that
assumption is wrong none of this stuff
works but every risk and return model in
finance is built on that Pres tion so
with that presumption that the cost of
equity in a company is going to be
estimated based so you're looking
through the eyes of vanard not through
your eyes or my eyes because you got to
be a price taker in this you don't set
the prices your cost of equity is going
to come from assessing and we'll talk
about how to come up with the BET and
the equity risk premum that you need but
effectively end game is a cost of equity
so we're almost there we got a cost of
debt we've got a cost of equity with
this gymnastics we did about with
assumptions we take a weighted average
final rule in DCF is those weights have
to be market value weights as opposed to
what you come out of an accounting class
where there's a shareholders equity in a
balance sheet never ever ever ever ever
should use a shareholders Equity from a
balance sheet as the equity when you do
cost Capal the weights and we'll talk
about why that rule is in
place but that's basically what
evaluation is going to look like so
that's what you're going to be doing for
the next seven eight nine weeks is going
through this process but I want you to
think about what this big picture is
leading so let's talk now
about the sequence here and this is a
sequence that works for me work with
whatever sequence we're going to start
by at least getting a sense of know what
the past looks like then we're going to
talk about risk and discount rates
because I've given you at least in
generic terms how do we estimate the
default risk in a company and come up
with the default spread how do we come
up with a b and an equity risk premium
how do we even come up with the risk
free rate that you need for
both so we're going to start with risk
and discount rate second we're going to
come up with taking past numbers and
projecting the past and here the
storytelling is going to kick in summer
along the way because you are telling a
story either of a continuation of the
past which is the easy story or a break
from the past a much more difficult
story step four we're going to talk
about apply that closure you got to your
five or 10 you're tired you want don't
want to do this anymore I'm going to
give you an escape hatch but it comes
with all kinds of
Clauses of what you can or cannot do and
finally I'm going to tie up loose sets
getting from the value of the firm to
Value back so let's start with the first
step in the process the D in the
discount I mean I'm going to start with
a statement that's obvious does a d
matter in a DCF yes of course it's a D
in there but but it doesn't matter as
much as most people think it does in my
from my view my from my perspective when
I look at people doing DCF Bankers
analyst they spend way too much time on
the D part and way too little time on
the cash flow if you're doing a healthy
valuation I want you to think about this
when you do your valuation you should be
spending maybe 10 to 20% of your time
coming up at the day the bulk of your
time should be coming up with the cash
flows but you know why people like the D
because you can do what I call false
Precision carry things to the third
decimal point look I've got this nailed
on the cash flows are terrifying right
you got to think about business models
and revenue growth and
margins but discount rates have to
maintain those consist I've already
given you one consistency rule if you
have Equity cash flows I said use the
cost of equity for I gave we talked
about the second decision rule cash you
tell me what currency you do the
valuation in your cash flows have to be
in the same currency Brazilian R
discount rate Brazilian re cash flows US
dollar discount rate US dollar cash
flows and if you choose to make your
numbers real I don't have a problem with
that but make sure you do it on both the
cash flows and the discount
R so
let's break
down where we're going with discard
reg so if you want to come up with a
cost of equity a risk adjusted cost of
equity you have to start with a risk
create there's no way you can do
discounted cash flow valuation if you
you can't tell me what a risk free rate
is and I'll talk about what goes into a
risk free rate but yes start then you
got to come up with a measure of
relative risk for your company is it
riskier than average safer than average
that's all the beta is right when you
say beta for a stock is 1.2 you're
saying it's 1.2 times as risky as the
average stock and then you got to tell
me what the price of risk looks like in
the equity
Market again I'm going to ask you
generic question don't think about the
specifics it's called an equity risk
premium the price of risk in the equity
Market
do something
today did it go up
down are you feeling a little more
nervous today than you were if you're an
investor then Friday I think so Equity
risk premiums are reflections of all
your hopes and fears right you the covid
crisis hits you get more scared you
Equity the price of risk is a number
that's Dynamic we'll talk about
estimation processes but that's what
you're trying to estim so that's what
you're trying to build into the discount
rate the risk-free rate the relative
risk measure and Equity risk so let's
talk a little bit
about
uncertainty because we put it all into
one bucket but one of the things that
can happen when you think about all
uncertainty is you can get overwhelmed I
tell people to list out all the things
that they're uncertain about with their
company just as a as a list and when you
look at the list you say oh my God I
can't deal with this because if you're
are honest you take inidia think about
all the things you're uncertain about
starting with where did I say that chips
were being
made Taiwan and you then say what if
China decides to cross over into Taiwan
well there goes your tsmc part of the
valuation right see that won't happen
well that's got to be considered so if
you make a list and you see 37 items on
the list you say I give up you know
there too much uncertainty so what I'd
like you to think about are buckets into
which you're going to put the different
uncertainties so here's the first
bucketing scheme is your uncertainty
that you're worried about estimation
uncertainty or is it economic
uncertainty let's start with estimation
let's start with the the estimation
uncertainty estimation UNC is you know
maybe I got this this margin number
wrong because I haven't it's basically
you know getting the details right
collecting more data will reduce
estimation uncertainty what's economic
uncertainty the China risk the fact that
deep sea could change the
business economic uncertainty you can do
nothing
about what I'm preparing you for the
moment when you're done with
evaluation you're going to look at the
value say I feel very uncertain then
what are you trying to do next go
collect more data because that will make
my valuation more precise you got to let
go there's a there's a point which I
call the karmic point which is I've done
all I can I've got to let go because
economic uncertainty you can do all the
research you want but guess what
economic uncertainty is still going to
be there 90% of the uncertainty you'll
face in most companies is economic
uncertainty doing more research is not
going to make it
go estimation uncertainty economic
uncertainty that's for your sanity
because once you make that divide you
realize what you can change by doing
more work and what you Cann second
bucketing micro uncertainty versus macro
uncertainty
take Tesla what are the micro
uncertainties uncertainties related to
the company right basically will their
electric carb get cheap or will they be
able to compete with B byd who's
actually running the company right now
so micro uncertainties uncertainties
relate to the company what are macro
uncertainties what will inflation look
like interest rates look like what do
government subsidies for electric cars
look like you saying why bother micro
you know the types of uncertainties that
show up in your discount rate if you're
Fidelity I said the risk you care about
is a risk you cannot diversify away risk
added to a portfolio the discount rate
in valuation captures macro uncertainty
not micro uncertainty because the
because a micro uncertainties average
out right for 100 companies things cut
so micro versus macro and there's a
third classification that I find useful
uncertainty can be either
discrete or continuous you give you a
very simple example of risk where you
can see the distinction until about 20
years ago and there are still countries
where this true used to have fixed
exchange rate regimes and floating rate
exchange rate regimes so the dollar euro
is a floating rate regime what does that
mean every moment of the day the
exchange rate changes it's bad right
because it means your cash flows are
changing as you go from one to the other
that's continuous uncertain whereas if
you are working with a currency where
it's a fixed exchange rate things look
really stable right it's the same
exchange rate every day until it isn't
but there a devaluation or revaluation
that's discrete uncertainty me ask you a
question if you're running a business
you think it's easier to live with
continuous risk or discrete
risk continuous risk I can offer you all
kinds of
tools discrete
risk is incredibly problematic let's
face it in finance we're very good at
dealing with continuous risk you know
what we do with discrete risk we act as
if it's not there or we let the
insurance company come in and deal with
it but what if it's not
insurable discret RIS so when you make a
list of risks so this of course needs
you to pick a company and you start
listing them it's going to go into one
of these buckets so here are the broad
themes that are going to drive how we
think about risk not all risk matters so
when you look at a compan like Tesla you
might worry about you know the electric
car model and whether the you know but
those are company specific risk they
will not show up in your discount rate
doesn't mean they won't affect your cash
flows but they they won't affect the
discount rate second when you look at
risk it's not what you see in the
company it's what Vanguard it's very
difficult to do because it's almost like
you got to set yourself to the side and
think about what would a diversified
investor see in this company because
you're a market price taker when it
comes to risk premum cost faity and
third the reason that matters is if you
look at most companies and you're going
and and I'll give you a way of looking
up the top 15 stockholders in your
company in most of your companies those
top stockholders are institutional
investors who Diversified and when you
diversify company specific or micro risk
gets averaged out it's not magic it's
the law of large numbers and statistics
some companies do better than expected
others do worse than
expected so with that long lead in I've
LED you into almost every finance class
we take these we'll spend weeks talking
about risk and return models I'm going
to spend three minutes talking about
that because this is not the purpose of
my class ultimately all risk and return
models and finance make the assumptions
I talked about looking at risk Through
The Eyes of a diversified investor what
they disagree on is how to measure the
risk you cannot diversify away the
oldest risk and return model in finance
is called the capital asset pricing
model it's been around since 19
1964 the developers M Bill Shar and John
Linton have both won Nobel prices it's
what you might have encountered in your
work if you worked at a back when you
use a beta using the capital asset
pricing model and what do you need for
it a risk free rate a beta and an equity
risk premium that number in the
brackets about 20 more than that 46
years
1978 an alternative came up to the
capital asset pricing model called the
Arbitrage pricing model don't get caught
up in the basically what it does take
that one beta and allows you to have
four or five betas depending on how many
sources of Market risk there are still
in the market risk Dimension so it's
just an expanded version you put names
on the factors because the original
Arbitrage pricing model is statistical
model where the factors were Factor one
factor two factor three you name those
factors into the yield curve or interest
rate levels you got a macro or a
multifactor mod still doing the same
things the only difference in One beta
you have multiple betas and in the late
late 80s you
had researchers for Chicago Farmer Jee
farm and Ken French who said why are we
even trying to estimate the risk let's
let the market tell us what's risky and
what's say you see how would the market
tell us they looked at 50 years of
Returns on stocks and they looked at
what stocks earned High returns they
found that small cab companies with low
price to book ratios or high returns
that must mean they're riskier you given
an up and measuring risk you essentially
let these are called proxy models for
risk but they're all trying to do the
same
thing if you're doing a evaluation and
let's say you use the cap app and there
is this person on the other side this is
a pain in the neck and he insist he
wants to use a multiactor model you know
what you should do just give it it's not
going to make much of a difference this
is not the fight you want to
fight it's not worth it because it
doesn't make much of a difference your
ultimate value I use the capm and I use
with open eyes I recognize the
limitations but if you push me on it
I'll say you know what I'll give up on
it I'll give you alternatives to even
these risk and return models ultimately
I want a risk adjusted
discount so if you look at the capital
asset pricing model there are three
items I need to get to an
expected I need a risk-free rate and
whatever currency you pick that's what
we're going to do for the rest of today
I need an equity risk premium for
investing in equities as a
class and I need a beta or a relative
risk measure that's it
right you know when I did my MBA 1979
through 81 you know how much time you
spent on the risk free rate in two years
I spent two minutes on the risk free
rate I was told to use the US Treasury
rate and we just moved on shows you how
dollar Centric my NBA program was and
how much trust there was that if you
bought a US treasury it was in fact
risk-free those days are done we're
going to spend a lot more than two
minutes because I want to talk about the
risk free rate so let me Define what I
think of when I think about something
being risk- free first if I have a truly
risk-free investment I should be able to
tell you my my expected return will
always be my actual return there's no
variance around
it so let's play a game Let's assume you
have a one-year time
Horizon and you buy a one-year
T and let's assume for the moment the US
Treasury is default free that's an
assumption right it's not a given one
year from now when I come and knock on
your door right now onee T bill is at
4.23% you could buy it on the US
Treasury auction so I can put my money
for one year at 4.23% one year from now
when I cash out that investment what's
my actual return going to be
no it's a one-year table I know exactly
what it'll be it be
4.23% doesn't matter it's a one-ear
table it's done right it's principle
being paid back that's why I made it one
year if I bought a 10year Tor you'd be
right a one-year table is risk-free with
a one-year timer I'm glad you brought up
the issue of price risk because if I
bought a 10year t-bond even if the
treasury is not default free then that
investment is not risk- free why because
then if interest rates move and the
return on the bond
changes I'm going to have a return
that's very different from my coupon
right I need to know exactly what I will
make with certainty so here are the
requirements for something to be rree
there can be no default risk and there
can be no reinvestment risk if you have
a 10year time Horizon a one-year T is
not risk free why not because at the end
of a year you got to reinvest at what
rate I have no
idea so when somebody asks what's the
risk free rate before you answer there
are two questions you need to ask them
what's the first
question what time frame right and
second don't forget ask what currency
maybe they want a Venezuelan bolevard
risk-free rate in which case giving them
a t- bond rate is completely meaningless
what there is no such thing as the risk
free
rate this will depend on currency and
time frame so time Horizon matters
currencies clearly matter and not all
government securities are necessary
give you risk free you know what the
story is as to why government bonds are
risk free right is it because
governments are incredibly efficiently
run entities what's the power that
governments have that makes them they
can print more money you can try but
it's not legal
right that's the argument for why but it
turns out to be a false argument I'll
explain why because just because a
government can print money doesn't mean
it will you know that half of all
Sovereign
defaults in the last 50 years Sovereign
defaults of government's defaulting have
been in local currency so clearly
governments default there must be a
reason we'll talk about why it is that a
government that could print off the
money chooses not to but not all
government bonds are risk free so I'm
going to take you through a series of
exercises of five I think there are five
tests and by the end of the fifth test
you'll know everything you need to know
about risk free rates let's start with
the first one I'm valuing a US company
in US
Dollars I want a risk-free rate to use
in my valuation I'll give you the
choices I can use a three-month t-b a
10-year t- bond a 30-year t- Bond a tips
tips is actually a treasury bond which
is inflation protected which means you
know exactly what you will make in real
terms and then they'll pay the inflation
on top of that maybe I should use the
highest of these numbers because you're
a conservative person or maybe the
lowest of these numbers because you're a
daring person
or maybe it's none of the above in which
case I'd really like to know what your
answer is because it's a fundamental
choice I have to make so let's start
ruling what you don't want Sophia what
should not be on that
list and tell me why the three months
should not be on the
list for a company right basically it's
almost never do you do valuation with
the cash flow stop after 3 months so
because valuation inherently is a
long-term exercise a table rate should
never ever ever ever be used as a
risk-free rate valuation you might have
learned otherwise in your foundations
class but maybe they were talking about
risk-free over something that's much
more
shortterm what else should I knock off
the
less there the highest and lowest so
let's knock off a e and f what about D
but I but in my analysis I said cash
flows forever in US dollar right the
minute I say that I've chosen a currency
so you're right if I wanted to do things
in real terms I'd go with the tips rate
but since I'm not doing things in real
terms I'm going to cross out the tips as
well which leaves me with what the 10
year or the 30 year if I stay pure if I
were a
purist and Sophia I'm going to put here
because you reasoned your way to if I a
purist would I pick the 10 or the
30 because how did you describe
valuation you're estimating cash flows
forever 30 is closer to Forever than 10
neither is that close but let's face it
so if I were just picking a risk-free
rate in US dollars I'd pick the 30 and T
bond rate if you go on and look at every
one of my valuations I use the 10-year
t- bond rate and here's why this is the
start of the process right once I get a
risk free Rate My Equity risk premiums
and default spreads have to be estimated
relative to the risk rate and it's a
purely pragmatic effect it's easier to
estimate default spreads on a 10e rate
and here's why I have to find 10e
corporates to compared to the I can't
find 30-year corporate so practically
speaking I use the 10year t-bo rate and
my suggestion is whatever currency
you're working in you get to 10 years
the yield curve has already start to
flatten out don't go looking for
troubles I want a 30-year Bond I won't
do valuation not a stand worth taking
I'm going to use the 10year t- bond rate
but before I take the last step I'm
going to get down on my knees look up at
the skies and say please God let the US
Treasury not
default we've had this dance got really
close to the edge multiple times over
the last decade because we have this
debt limit and every time we get closed
there's a little US Treasury how many
times have you read the story of next
weekend the US government might shut
down that's an implicit assumption we're
making and we're talking about what
happens if I can't make that assumption
anymore so we use long-term RS everybody
with me on
that second stop let's suppose how many
any of you valuing a European company in
Euros who you valueing SE seens and it's
a German company anybody valuing any
European company that's not in
Germany
Sophia are you going to do your
valuation in Euros though okay so let's
pick somebody who's anybody else who's
valuing a European company in euros
I'm going to make you pick a Spanish
company pick a Spanish company doesn't
even have to have a name and you're
going to do your valuation in Euros so
both of you are valuing your company in
Euros both of you are going to look for
risk free rates I'm going to help you
out I'm going to give you the government
bond rate in euros and have a bit of a
problem you know why there's not one
10year Government Bond Euros there are a
dozen different governments that issue
10 year bonds and euros and the rates
are all different so there's pain and
there's
Germany so let me start with them you
want a Euro risk free rate would you use
the Spanish tenure rate or the German
rate and that's the answer I get from
most European analysts but these are all
tenure Bonds denominated in Euros right
this is not
1999 we talking about pesos and drmas
and French Franks and they're all EUR
robots so why are the rates different
across
default risk right and already you see
the problem with picking the Spanish
government Bond I wanted you pick a risk
free rate and you picked a rate which
has default risk in it so I'm going to
give you a second shot so which are the
rates you going to pick and
why it's the lowest it's not because
it's German the German has been the
lowest 10year Euro bond rate for as long
as I remember but it's getting awfully
close Germany's having its own set of
budget and economic problems the Dutch
rate is actually getting really close
and who knows next year when I do this
it might be the it's not because it's
German but because it's the lowest you
value any company in Euros anywhere in
the
world you're going to use the ger you
know part of you saying but what if it's
a Greek company I want to punish the
company for being Greek this is not the
place to do it I will give you plenty of
chances later on to revisit that issue
this is the risk reate same thing with
the Russian company now Sophia can
choose to value a Russian company and do
it in euros and she's going to use the
German Euro Bond rater but what about
the RK risk in Russia what are the two
other inputs waiting for
me an equity risk premium no evenin the
discount rate wa I'll give you a chance
when you get especially the equity risk
premium when you do risk free rates in
Euros you're going to go with the German
Euro bond rate but be very it's because
it's the lowest rate in fact there are
people who even suggest that maybe I
should go with the European Central Bank
rate because even the German don't
control their own money supply because
once you picked a common currency that's
what you give up so you want to use a
European Central Bank R it's actually
very close to German bond rate you can
use that instead but that's Euro let's
slim one step further up the difficulty
L it's January 2025 anybody valuing an
Indian company in
rupes okay who you
valuing Asar Technologies okay so you
want an Indian rupee risk free rate so
first you're going to go look for an
Indian Government Bond 10year Government
Bond in rupees you can find one it used
didn't used to be the case the rate at
the start of January 2025 was
82% I'm done risk create but before you
go and use that a zero screen what do
you have to check is there default risk
in there going to help you along the
way if any of you have visited the
moodies or the SNP website there's a
section of the website for Sovereign
ratings basically Moody and S&P and fit
all great
countries not companies countries and
they give two ratings for every country
a local currency rating and a foreign
currency rating what's a foreign
currency rating for India it measures
the default risk in India if it borrows
money in Euros or dollars or Yen the
local currency rating at least in theory
is the risk that Moody sees in India if
it borrows money in
rupees as you check that rating what
you're hoping and pray what will make
your life easy see a AAA rating because
then if something goes wrong you can
blame
Moody at the start of 2025 the rating
for India was b83 what does that tell
you that that
6.82% is not quite risk- free there's
some default risk so think of this as an
algebra problem if you can just figure
out what that default risk is and take
it out make it risk free right I'll help
you along the way and I'll come back and
flesh this out later this week the
default spread for a b A3 rated country
in early January 2025 was
2.18% so can you bring those two piece
of information together with the risk
rate
yeah you try to reason it out in in open
space is what you're trying to do yeah
exactly that's exactly what it is is
6.82% is default spread so let's reason
it out so 2.18%
is a default spread so what are you
going to do take it out or add it back
you got a 50/50 shot take it out right
don't add it back that'll be double
counting you take it out my risk free
rate in Indian rupes is
4.64% little more work not the he's
saying can I do this with Russian rubles
well there's a problem you know what the
problem
is 2 years ago the ratings agency
stopped raing
Russia until two years ago you could
have done this with rubles as well I
used to do this when I valued companies
and rubles we'll talk about what to do
when countries are no longer raid but
for countries that are raid you can
start with the government bond rate so
this default spread number becomes a
number you got to estimate I'll give you
three Pathways you can use to get the
default spread for a country much of
Latin America Brazil Peru
Chile the government issues Bonds in US
dollars as well as in the local currenc
so Brazil has a 10year dollar bond out
there right now let's say the Brazilian
dollar bond is at four and a half let's
say it's at 6 and a half% the t- bond is
at 4 and a half% that difference is a
default spread you can do this only if
they're in the same currency some
European governments issue Bonds in
Euros you can compare that to the German
Euro bond that spread is a default
spread that's a first approach the
second is a market that is of fairly
recent Origins called The Sovereign CDs
Market
Sovereign CDs Market is a market where
investors assess the risk of a country
and they come it's a market set number
so you can't blame S&P and Moody's for
this this basically is what market
demand and supplies it's a market
estimate of the default spread it's all
more updated but it's also going to be
more volatile markets
are so for countries which have a rate
which have a sovereign CDs spread or
dollar denominated bonds I can use it
what if you don't have both and all you
have is a rating I have a lookup table
that I've created that I use existing
bonds and at the start of every year I
update this so you tell me what your
rating is for a country I'll tell you
what the default spread that's a
2.18% which is the best one there is no
best one there is really what works for
you but as long as you stay consent
you're going to be okay but that's
basically so I'm going to close off
today with what those three numbers look
like for Brazil at the start of
2025 first one is Government Bond rate
7.75% 10year Government Bond in dollars
4.58% was the USD bond rate the
difference
3.17% is my default spread for Brazil
works because they both have dollar
bonds Sovereign CDs Market 3.23% Market
at number I net out the default spread
for the us because some of that default
spread is really not for default for the
fact that the market is structural but
either way you're getting a market
measure a little different from the bond
market
market and finally you give me the
rating for Brazil I think the actual
rating is baa is end up with 2.83% three
different default spreads so the start
of the next class we're going to start
with those three default spreads and
work them through to come up with risk
free rates in so I'll see you in one
sec have you reconciled
that's it that's the only thing